ووصف الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قرار
واشنطن تزويد اوكرانيا ضد خائر العنقوديه
وصفه بالصعب وقال خلال لقائه مع شبكه سي
ان الاخباريه انه عمل بموجب توصيه وزاره
الدفاع لتزويد كياف مؤقتا بهذا النوع من
الذخائر بسبب النقص في الذخائر الاخرى
لقد كان ذلك قرارا صعبا للغايه بالنسبه لي
وقد ناقشت الامر مع حلفائنا ومع الكونجرس
نحن الان في وضع تتعرض فيه اوكرانيا
باستمرار لهجمات وحشيه بالذخائر العنقوديه
التي تشكل خطوره على المدنيين هذا اولا
وثانيا مخزون الذخائر لدى الاوكرانيين بدا
بالنفاذ من نوع 155 ملم ولدينا معدلات
قليله منها لذلك اخذت بتوصيه وزاره الدفاع
للسماح بتزويد الاوكرانيين بالذخائر
العنقوديه لحين توفير البديل من النوع
السابق
من جهه قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
انه تم ابلاغ الحلفاء بخمسه مبادئ رئيسيه
بخصوص الذخائر العنقوديه ومنها عدم
استخدامها في روسيا وفي مناطق ماهوله
بالمدني